there are beds here for as far as the
eye can see
Spain is on a war footing in the fight
against coronavirus it means makeshift
hospitals like this one in Madrid have
been built on an industrial scale the
country's been badly wounded by the
covert 19 disease but in all the misery
and death doctors are starting to see
some hope but little by little it's a
very hard place a very hard situation
in my career of an internal medicine
doctor I haven't seen any anytime
suppose this would happen it's a very
hard situation because there were a lot
of patients the hospital was set up in
the space of just two weeks in what is
normally an Exhibition Centre some of
the first sick people treated here are
now starting to recover 50 year-old
jounin bas Terra was hospitalized ten
days ago and is hoping to be discharged
soon hi jounin I how you how you feeling
he told me by a videophone the country's
improving health is thanks to the strict
lockdown even if it is at the expense of
the economy
and Spain has made that choice for the
moment
saving lives means another extension to
the country's shut down until the end of
April the majority of Spaniards live in
apartments and can't go out even for
exercise social living here is on hold
for the moment shouting from balcony to
balcony is now the music of community
life on street level the capital is
ghostly quiet apart from a central
shopping the day and nights will be
spent inside for most people the log
down here in Spain is far stricter than
it is in the UK we've just watched in
the last few minutes as the police have
come here in central Madrid they've set
up a random checkpoint they're now
stopping motorists they're checking
their documents to make sure that they
are legally allowed to be out on the
roads and this is what it's like all the
time
breaking the lockdown in Spain is a
serious offence and throughout the day
we were stopped and our documents
checked to make sure we were legitimate
key workers with nearly three weeks of
lockdown still left the question now is
how can this country haunted by the
coronavirus reopen its economy without
causing another spike in infections
Alex Rossi Sky News Madrid